[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem samstag
die vom sport hat tradition formel 1 und
fußball den schönen guten abend und da
sind einige unserer themen
klares nein zu jamaika die grüne jugend
macht druck auf die parteispitze und
auch viele junge liberale setzen nicht
mehr auf die union
spannung in tschechien bei der
parlamentswahl liegt regierungschef
barbisch zwar knapp vorn muss aber
trotzdem um die macht bangen
und party in der giga factory mit einem
volksfest auf der baustelle in
brandenburg wirbt tesla um die gunst der
anwohner
im moment hat rot grün gelb die besten
chancen an die regierung zu kommen am
montag gehen die gespräche weiter die
atmosphäre ist offenbar gut das dürfe
aber nicht darüber hinweg täuschen sagt
grünen-chef habeck dass die differenzen
zwischen den parteien noch erheblich
sein das sieht auch der nachwuchs von
fdp und grünen so und stellt deutliche
forderungen die gewicht haben
schließlich waren es vor allem die
jungen die grünen und geldwerten britta
buchholz
die jungen nie waren sie so stark nie so
wichtig beim parteitag der grünen jugend
warnen sie vor zu vielen kompromissen
ampel auf grün das jahr aber mit den
richtigen zielen mehr klimaschutz mehr
soziale gerechtigkeit aber wie viel darf
das kosten der zankapfel mit der fdp
gerade wenn wir darüber reden ob wir
löhne anheben wenn wir darüber reden ob
ausbildungsplätze garantiert werden wenn
wir darüber reden was mit hartz4
passieren soll trennt uns sehr viel und
das hörte es gibt große bereitschaft für
gemeinsame einigungen aber auch die fdp
wird am ende des tages nicht einfach nur
klientelpolitik bereiche machen können
aber die wünsche der grünen kosten viel
geld höherer mindestlohn mehr hartz 4
sie weiß dass ricarda lang sitzen mit am
sondierungs tisch ihr appell
wir dürfen uns nicht in der form einer
jungen generation verschulden dass wir
in zukunft kaputt gespart schule ein
gesundheitssystem in dem die mit mir
arbeiten will oder im planeten auf dem
er nicht mehr gut leben kann haben dafür
müssen investieren das ist die aufgabe
für nächste regierung wie wir dahin
kommen dazu kann ich wenig sagen weil
ich glaube vertraulichkeit ist gerade
das was diese gespräche zum erfolg
führen wird aber wie sehen das die
jungen bei der fdp in nordrhein
westfalen treffen sich die dortigen
jungen liberalen beim landeskongress der
bundesvorsitzende mahnt kompromiss an
wir glauben nicht dass wir mit lasten
fahrräder den klimaschutz schaffen
sondern mit innovationen und
technologien wie global denken müssen
und alle denken neu jamaika ist vom
tisch jedenfalls erst einmal aber es
wird nicht leicht
wenn man in richtung steuerpolitik geht
in richtung finanzpolitik ich glaube da
haben wir sehr unterschiedliche
herangehensweisen da werden wir
natürlich kompromisse machen müssen und
die können natürlich auch wehtun ich
meine liebesbeziehung gibt es selten in
der politik man hat natürlich
verschiedene inhalte einfach deswegen
ist man auch in genau der eigenen partei
fdp und grüne beide wissen sie müssen
die jungen sehen keine leichte aufgabe
für die sondierung bei solchen
unterschieden
zwei prominente cdu politiker teilten
heute mit dass sie doch nicht in den
bundestag gehen
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer und wirtschaftsminister
altmaier verzichten auf ihre mandate
zwei jüngere parteifreunde aus dem
saarland rücken für sie nach es sei
wichtig jetzt einen generationswechsel
herbeizuführen hieß es zur begründung
tschechien hat ein neues parlament
gewählt ersten ergebnissen zufolge liegt
die partei von ministerpräsident andré
habisch knapp vorn die bildung einer
neuen regierung dürfte für ihn
allerdings schwierig werden der multi
milliardär gilt als hoch umstritten in
seine amtszeit fallen mehrere
betrugsskandale die vorwürfe korruption
steuerhinterziehung und jüngst
hinzugekommen verdeckte
immobiliengeschäfte britta hilpert
berichtet
es sind mehr wahlzettel als sonst die
sie zu zählen haben die beteiligung ist
hoch um die 65 prozent denn es ist eine
richtungswahl für oder gegen ihn
ministerpräsident barbisch hat an
stimmen verloren rund 27 das ist zwar
stärkste einzelpartei aber keine
mehrheit denn er polarisiert labiche
barbisch sichert ganz tschechien
rentnern sehr geholfen
ich hoffe dass die kommende regierung
nicht cloud lügt und betrügt und so habe
ich auch gewählt
fabisch ist immer wieder mittelpunkt von
skandalen zuletzt kam heraus dass er in
frankreich unter anderem ein schloss
gekauft hatte über offshore firmen nach
tschechischem recht hätte er das publik
machen müssen nur einer von mehreren
seiner konflikte mit regeln und gesetzen
subventionsbetrug in diesem hotel und
interessenkonflikt wirft ihnen die eu
kommission vor am ende haben diese
skandale wohl mehr wähler für die
opposition mobilisiert für das
parteienbündnis der mitte rechts und für
die linksliberalen pirat ist als die
hochrechnung sie vorne sehen
war gekommen weil anscheinend haben sie
genug von der regierung gibt es jetzt
statt doch der gebrechliche
staatspräsident seemann entscheidet wer
die regierung bilden darf er gilt als
verbündeter von barbies im prager
regierungsviertel kann die
regierungsbildung noch spannend werden
spannend könnte es heute auch noch in
österreich werden da steht kanzler kurz
enorm unter druck und er will sich
gleich noch äußern heißt es britta
hilpert in wien was können sie uns dazu
sagen
sebastian kurz hat überraschend zu einer
pressekonferenz um 19 uhr 30 gebeten und
es verdichten sich die hinweise zwei
boulevard medien berichten dass
sebastian kurz seine kanzlerschaft
zurückgeben will auch die
österreichische presseagentur apa
berichtet dass das nun im raum stünde
der außenminister schallenberg stünde
wohl als ersatz sozusagen
bereit es heißt im hintergrund dass die
bundesländer österreichs auf diese
lösung gedrängt hätten aber das ganze
ist noch mit einem körnchen salz zu
nehmen denn gestern rief sebastian kurz
auch kurzfristig zu einer
pressekonferenz und am ende war da gar
nichts neues von ihnen zu hören also wir
müssen noch ein bisschen abwarten um die
letzte bestätigen zu erfahren sicher ist
wenn er heute nicht zurücktritt dann
wird er am dienstag bei einem
misstrauensvotum sehr wahrscheinlich
zurückgetreten werden
dankeschön britta hilpert nach wien
spätestens im heute-journal wissen wir
wohl mehr die usa haben erstmals wieder
direkte gespräche mit den taliban
geführt in der katarischen hauptstadt
doha es gehe dabei nicht um anerkennung
oder legitimierung der neuen herrscher
in afghanistan hieß es im vorfeld
vielmehr sollten pragmatische lösungen
gefunden werden wie weitere us bürger
und andere ausländer sicher aus
afghanistan ausreisen können
dauerkrise das gilt nicht nur für
afghanistan das gilt auch für den irak
hier wird heute und morgen ein neues
parlament gewählt vor etwa vier jahren
erlebte das land einen moment der
hoffnung der militärische sieg über die
terroristen des sogenannten islamischen
staates verbessert hat sich die
sicherheitslage sonst aber nicht viel
noch immer sind gebiete zerstört vom
krieg die hohe arbeitslosigkeit ist ein
enormes problem genau wie die korruption
eine brühe berichtet
so hatte ahmed sich sein leben nicht
vorgestellt schule abgeschlossenes
studium jetzt verkauft er saft auf den
straßen von bagdad
ich habe einen miesen job das ist kein
leben keine zukunft
irak steckt in der krise politisch und
wirtschaftlich die landeswährung
abgewertet die arbeitslosigkeit hoch
das leben ist so schwer kein wasser
keine elektrizität die armen können sich
die mieten nicht mehr leisten
immer dieselben gesichter selbst wenn
sie sich ändern die gehören noch alle zu
denselben parteien
diesmal sind zwar auch unabhängige
kandidaten zugelassen außerhalb der
etablierten parteien trotzdem befürchten
beobachter dass die wahlbeteiligung
niedrig sein könnte
ein teil der jugend will die wahlen
boykottieren vor zwei jahren hatten sie
hier auf dem tahir platz in bagdad mit
protesten begonnen die blutig
niedergeknüppelt wurden aktivisten
müssen weiter um ihr leben fürchten bis
heute gibt es hunderte tote und keinen
der dafür zur rechenschaft gezogen wird
checkpoints gehören zum alltag in bagdad
zur wahl wurden die sicherheitsmaßnahmen
noch einmal verstärkt zwar ist die
islamistische terrorgruppe es offiziell
seit 2000 17 besiegt aber noch immer
gibt es einzelne zellen im land gibt es
anschläge von der politik aber erwarten
sie mehr als sicherheit auch saft
verkäufer ahmed wird deshalb wohl nicht
zur wahl gehen
wann immer es wahlen gibt passiert doch
immer das gleiche es gibt einfach keine
veränderungen
ahmed will nicht aufgeben hofft weiter
auf ein land in dem ein studienabschluss
einen guten job garantiert und eine wahl
die zukunft verspricht
beim internet netzwerk facebook hat es
zum zweiten mal innerhalb einer woche
weltweit technische probleme gegeben
diesmal für etwas zwei stunden auch
instagram und whatsapp waren betroffen
schon am montag konnten facebook dienste
rund sechs stunden lang nicht erreicht
werden betroffen waren dreieinhalb
milliarden nutzer das unternehmen
erklärte die störungen mit
konfigurationsfehler
in berlin gab es gestern abend eine
attacke auf einen ehemaligen
israelischen soldaten unbekannte
sprühten dem 29-jährigen reizgas ins
gesicht und stießen ihn zu boden zuvor
hätten sie ihn auf seinen jüdischen
glauben angesprochen der berliner hatte
einen pullover mit dem emblem der
israelischen verteidigungsstreitkräfte
getragen das lka ermittelt
antisemitismus ist bittere realität in
deutschland zum zweiten mal jährt sich
heute der terroranschlag von halle
diese massive tür verhinderte dass ein
schwerbewaffneter rechtsextremer in die
synagoge ein drang am höchsten jüdischen
feiertag jom kippur stattdessen erschoss
er eine passantin und einen mann in
einem türkischen imbiss vom gedenken in
halle berichtet luisa
halle hält inne
die stadt gedenkt der opfer des
rechtsextremistischen anschlags von vor
zwei jahren
die tat hat ihre spuren hinterlassen
mir ist ja nichts passiert aber
ungemacht vor allen dingen die ganze
entwicklung der hast ja immer größer
wird
sorge und wort davor habe ich angst
es ist mir wirklich dazu kommen war ich
denke dass man diesen anschlag geben
nicht vergessen darf und generell hat
auf das ganze thema aufmerksam machen
muss
und ja so ich meine dass es passiert es
ist absolut grausam und es darf auf
keinen fall wiederholen bei der heutigen
gedenkveranstaltung rief
ministerpräsident haseloff die
bevölkerung auf rechtsextremismus und
antisemitismus die stirn zu bieten
außerdem warnte er vor einer verrohung
der sprache
sprache
2010 hat gezeigt
und sind oft nicht so weit voneinander
entfernt dieser imbiss war ebenfalls
ziel des attentäters als die politik
vertreter dort heute kränze niederlegten
war sein besitzer es mit tekin
absichtlich nicht dabei er fühlt sich
nicht wahrgenommen weil keiner der
verantwortlichen politiker mit ihm im
vorhinein gesprochen habe er erwartet
mehr als nur gesten
es gibt den betroffenen zu unterstützen
manchmal braucht man halt von schöne
wörter ist es ist fehlt die komplette
kommunikation seite bis jetzt mit
helfern aus dem viertel baut ismet tekin
seinen imbiss zu einem kaffee um er
hofft auf einen neuanfang
tesla chef elon musk weiß sich und seine
produkte in szene zu setzen heute mit
großer party in brandenburg tausende
gäste dürfen europas erstes tesla werk
inspizieren der andrang ist immens die
kritik wie immer auch schließlich baut
magna ein riesending in einem
wasserschutzgebiet bislang noch ohne
endgültige baugenehmigung meyer
berichtet die tester fabrik in grünheide
ist noch nicht fertig gefeiert wird
trotzdem 9000 menschen sehen sich in den
produktionshallen um aufwand von ihnen
musk der am abend selbst das fest
besucht sind vor allem berliner und
brandenburger eingehen
schön dass auch mal wieder in
deutschland investiert wird es gibt ja
auch genug firmen die nur ins ausland
investieren und diesmal ist das anders
das ja für die region oder für
deutschland auch einen gewinn die medien
bleiben weitgehend ausgeschlossen sowie
auch die bürgerinitiative vor dem firmen
eingang die aktivisten befürchten
verkehrschaos die verschmutzung von
wasser und luft und haben teil erfolge
errungen so hat tesla seinen
ursprünglich geplanten wasserverbrauch
deutlich reduziert doch haben sie kaum
hoffnung die auto- und
batterieproduktion ganz zu verhindern
unsere arbeit geht natürlich weiter also
wir werden weiter kämpfen das halt
weitere auflagen hier erfolgen und die
und die nicht einfach machen können was
sie wollen für das fest unter corona
bedingungen gaben die behörden eine
ausnahmegenehmigung sowie für den
gesamten bau bisher 15 teil zulassungen
wurden erteilt die endgültige
genehmigung steht noch immer aus
ich bin an der stelle optimistisch dass
dieses jahr noch ein auto vom band
runter laufen wird ist dann kann das
ergebnis natürlich nicht vorwegnehmen es
ist noch ein laufendes verfahren noch
arbeiten die roboter nur im testbetrieb
bis nächste woche läuft online die
zweite öffentliche anhörung erst danach
wird das landesumweltamt entscheiden ob
in grünheide wirklich bis zu 500.000
autos pro jahr produziert werden
endlich wieder in den urlaub fliegen der
start der herbstferien in einigen
bundesländern führte zu enormen
schlangen an deutschen flughäfen
vor allem wegen der korona maßnahmen
dauert alles deutlich länger in hannover
kam zum anderen unter pandemie
bedingungen noch ein zusätzliches
problem ein streik das
sicherheitspersonal kritisiert schlechte
arbeitsbedingungen und personalmangel
der anfang vom urlaub war also nicht nur
hier ganz schön anstrengend
anstrengend fußball gestern war
ich ganz happy wieder ein wichtiger
schritt gewesen nach dem 2 1 sieg gegen
rumänien nimmt die deutsche
fußball-nationalmannschaft klar kurs auf
die wm endrunde im nächsten jahr in
katar der vierte sieg im vierten spiel
unter bundestrainer hansi flick glück
auch dank des starken bayern blocks mit
dem er in münchen zum titel sammler
wurde sorgen gibt es nur um den kapitän
manuel neuer der gestern wegen
muskulärer probleme pausieren musste ist
auch heute noch nicht fit sein
stellvertreter marc andré ter stegen
konnte den ersten gegentreffer in der
ära flick nicht verhindern nach dem
frühen rückstand sind es zwei
bayern-stars die entscheidend dazu
beitragen dass die partie noch gedreht
wird zunächst der starke cash carry mit
dem ausgleich sein zwanzigster treffer
im dreißigsten länderspiel und dann
gelingt dem eingewechselten thomas
müller in seinem premierenspiel unter
fliegt das 2 1 es war ein sieg der
mentalität es wird auch dazu in der
entwicklung die wir gerade haben dass
man auch so spiele dann wenn es mal
nicht so läuft wie man sich das
vorstellt dass man da wird trotzdem aber
letztendlich mit voller begeisterung an
überzeugung dieses spiel auch beendet ob
kapitän neuer übermorgen gegen nord
mazedonien spielen kann ist weiterhin
offen
mercedes-pilot valtteri bottas sichert
sich die pole position beim großen preis
der türkei schnellster im qualifying ist
zwar lewis hamilton der
rekordweltmeister wird aber wegen eines
regelwidrigen motoren wechsels auf den
elften startplatz zurückversetzt
gebremste freude über die bestzeit bei
hamilton und seinen fans der wm-führende
aus england setzt am 16 rennwochenende
der saison einen neuen verbrennungsmotor
ein weil es der vierte des jahres ist
wird er automatisch um zehn startplätze
zurückversetzt seinen mercedes
teamkollegen valtteri bottas aus
finnland profitiert als zweitschnellster
davon und übernimmt am sonntag
startplatz eins vor dem niederländer max
verstappen der in istanbul am thron von
hamilton rütteln will in seiner ersten
formel 1 saison erreicht mit schumacher
zum zweiten mal den zweiten
qualifikationsdurchgang ein grund zum
feiern
so weit vorn war er noch nie der sohn
von michael schumacher kommt im
unterlegenen auto des us motorsport
teams haas auf rang 14
noch schöner erfolg das was dankeschön
morgen wird es nochmals sonnig wie es
danach weitergeht erklärt gleich katja
horneffer das heute journal mit marietta
slomka um viertel nach elf wir wünschen
ihnen noch einen richtig schönen abend
und bis morgen wenn sie mögen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend schon über eine woche hält
uns das tief christian in atem hier in
europa mit kräftigen regenmengen
zunächst im zentralmassiv auch über
norditalien und jetzt paul tief
christian das östliche mittelmeer für
uns in deutschland interessant sind am
wochenende jetzt hoch die ober und
hochrhein bürger die bringen viel
sonnenschein und anfang der kommenden
woche mit dann tief in mitbringt erst
regen und dann auch deutlich tiefere
temperaturen heute gab es jetzt unter
nebel und hochnebel die lösten sich aber
rasch auf zum beispiel hier in thüringen
auch südlich von münchen oder auch am
rhein und dann strahlte die sonne von
der küste bis zum alpenrand und deswegen
wird auch die nacht sehr klar losgehen
dann aber bildet sich nebel und es wird
eiskalt die temperaturen sinken auf plus
3 bis minus 3 grad es gibt also ganz
verbreiteten deutschland bodenfrost
minder bleibt die nacht am niederrhein
und auf den ostfriesischen inseln mit
sechs kracht morgen liegen die
temperaturen in der osthälfte bei 10 bis
14 im westen bei 14 bis 17 grad und es
gibt viel sonnenschein für sehr viele
allerdings hält sich auch mal nebel und
hochnebel zäh richtung bodensee und
alpenrand und von nord westen werden die
wolken dichter am montag kommt dann
langsam die wetterumstellung und dann
wird es deutlich kälter schönes
wochenende